in Japan there's an art form that by any
standard would be considered extreme
where the paintbrush is made of two
dozen needles and the canvas is human
flesh every inch of flesh from your
wrists to your ankles
it's called jaurim oh no Japanese
full-body tattoo
these full-body masterpieces can cost
tens of thousands of dollars and a
lifetime of suffering to complete I can
feel the needle going in and in and in
but for all that's endured to get one
these tattoos are usually hidden why go
to all that pain and suffering for
something few others will ever see
because showing can identify you as one
of the most notorious and feared members
of Japanese society
they're called Yakuza the gangsters of
Japan they inhabit a world of drug
running prostitution extortion and other
crimes in this realm forum Ono is a mark
of belonging as a result most Japanese
view hormone Oh as a symbol of the mob
unfit for public display but one man is
on a mission to change all that
eg Ruza King is a renowned hormone Oh
master known by the artist name hoary
coy hoary cow uses a time-honored design
that allows wearers to keep their ink
hidden under their clothes
these suits of tattoo are left bare in
strategic places hands feet and center
of the chest Samurai make a fierce
showing in many of these designs most
hormone owe is based on legendary
warriors and heroes whose tails have
symbolic meaning for the wearer the
images are typically drawn from classic
Japanese woodblock prints but tattoos
weren't always a matter of personal
aesthetics hundreds of years ago
Japanese authorities gave tattoos to
criminals as a form of punished
these tattoos allowed the public to
identify and ostracize wearers but by
the end of the 17th century outlaws were
hiding these tattoos with decorative
patterns some believe that the covering
of prison tattoos was the beginning of
the notorious link between organized
crime and jaurim oh no hoary coil Eve's
that the best way to change the
prejudiced against war mono is to take
it on in the flesh once a month he
organizes a performance at a local bar
exposing the public to a mix of karaoke
Japanese tradition and lorry moment by
putting a spotlight on jaurim Ono
Cory Cory hopes to remove the stigma
that has clung to it for so long it
would be very nice to eliminate that
prejudice his efforts may already be
working ever more people are turning to
Horry coin to transform their bodies
into living art this is my life and my
style I hope that people that understand
this join me and I will join them